three two one go that's phony instead of
the GG shoot today and I'm gonna be in
hot dog until hit a good shot I've been
a competitive eater for about the past
the four four and half years up since I
was 19 years old
uh-oh I think right now I hold our 12
World Records oh ho that's adding up
over the past few years but anyway
everything from like a euros the
Japanese dumplings pumpkin pie Twinkies
and Haman get started kind of a fluke
you know I was just I was in college so
there was a contest nearby a lobster
roll contest uh they said you know use
many lobsters as you can for free and if
you win eat the most lobsters you get a
thousand bucks so I end up winning the
contest popular thousand dollars and I'm
just like hey this is not that bad the
number get pretty high there's like
close to twenty one pounds of pumpkin
pie 84 slices made minutes obviously
this year did 62 hot dogs at the
unfortunately hot dog eating contest
earlier this year I did a 345 I think
adapt news nothing 10 minutes so um
there's some pretty impressive records
out there
it's hard to stay in shape you know as a
competitive eater it's crucial though
because a lot of the compares up onstage
you know they're not big guys are not
heavyset guys like you think cuz I it's
a ten minute sprint really both there
and you know I'm doing my cardio I'm
doing my weights I'm no I'm Superman or
anything you know it's pretty normal
diet especially I can't contest time you
know I'm cutting back I'm pretty minimal
between the practices and whatnot but
you know like in the offseason I'm just
normal guy just you know the food okay I
think we got nothing